today the Matt Walsh show the Biden
Administration has hired an obesity
expert to help craft new dietary
guidelines this expert says that obesity
is a brain disease and there's almost
nothing you can do to stop yourself from
becoming fat this is ridiculous of
course but it's part of a larger and
more nefarious agenda which we will
discuss today also the media launches a
campaign against assault pistols what
are those exactly a teen girl is
sexually harassed by a man in the
women's locker room at the YMCA now the
harasser is speaking out to defend
himself and somehow I do not find his
arguments persuasive plus a famous track
star claims racism and sexism after
getting kicked off of a plane is she
really a victim or just another cry
bully brat we'll talk about all that and
more today on the Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
the current administration's New Year's
goals are to tax spend and turn a blind
eye to inflation if this is at odds with
your goals if you're tired of the
government playing games with your
savings and your retirement plan then
you need to get in touch with the
experts at Birch gold today for over 5
000 years gold has withstood inflation
geopolitical turmoil and stock market
crashes now you can own gold and attack
shelter retirement account Birch gold
makes it easy to convert an IRA or 401K
into an IRA in Precious Metals text
Walsh to 98 98 98 to claim your claim
your free info kit on gold and then talk
to one of their precious metals
Specialists with an A plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau thousands of
happy customers and countless five-star
reviews you can trust Birch gold to help
protect your savings text Walsh to 98
9898 and protect yourself with gold
today that's Walsh to 98 98.98
last week during our mailbag segment in
the members block portion of the show
someone asked me to pinpoint the exact
moment when the downfall of Western
civilization began now my first answer
to that question which may or may not be
naively optimistic is that I'm not ready
to admit that the downfall of our
civilization has actually happened or is
happening we are fighting to avert such
a disaster and um if I didn't believe
that we could win that fight I wouldn't
bother with any of this that said we are
experiencing at the very least a steep
decline in nearly all senses of the term
civilizationally but I don't think it's
possible to locate an exact beginning
point of this devolutionary process we
cannot say precisely when we began on
this road but we can in retrospect
identify certain landmarks certain
signposts that we passed along the way
which warned of things to come and yet
whose warnings were not heated as for
that I mentioned uh in that segment one
moment that isn't often cited in
conversations like these and that moment
occurred in 1952 at the publication of
what would become the first of so far
five editions of the diagnostic and
statistical Manual of mental disorders
by the American Psychiatric association
what made this moment significant in an
ominous and very negative sort of way is
that it was one step followed by many
more increasingly larger and more rapid
steps towards the medicalization of The
Human Condition the psychiatric industry
had set out on a path towards
diseasifying every human emotion thought
action habit and recasting the human
species as pre-programmed and highly
defective automatons incapable of making
our own choices or of claiming any sort
of responsibility for our own emotional
and mental states by the publication of
the DSM-5 in 2013 this process was
complete or perhaps not because there's
always more that can be done after all
there are always more ways to relieve
human beings of the burden of their own
free will which has become perhaps the
number one mission right now of the
medical community it isn't just
psychiatrists anymore who are working
diligently on this project much of the
rest of the medical industry has joined
the cause and this is especially evident
in the way that medical experts now
approach and treat obesity
and in fact to bridge the gap between
these two topics we should note that a
serious effort was made to add obesity
to the DSM-5 officially categorizing it
as a mental illness
the kind of thing that you would talk to
your psychiatrist about not a
nutritionist and then be given
psychotropic drugs to treat and by the
way they would be treating of course not
the Obesity but your feelings about the
Obesity which would then actually become
the disease the fact that you're obese
and don't want to be obese that's the
problem let's make you okay with the
Obesity and then we've solved it it did
end up getting making it into the DSM-5
but I'm quite certain it'll be in the
dsm-6
um so because we haven't gotten quite to
that point yet but we have arrived at
the point where
as we discussed on the show a few weeks
ago so-called medical experts are
officially recommending gastric bypass
surgery and diet pills to obese children
because obesity they say is a disease in
its own right not something that you can
or should try to control on your own
um it's entirely a disease the
medicalization of gluttony and sloth
which are the true causes of obesity is
now in full swing
one of the people at the Forefront of
this movement is a woman named Fatima
Cody Stanford she's a doctor at
Massachusetts General Hospital and she
also works at Harvard Medical School
it's a very prestigious professional and
she recently added another prestigious
title to her resume when she was named
as a member on the 2025 dietary
guidelines advisory committee which is
assembled by the Departments of healthy
human services and agriculture
this committee which will hold its first
meeting in a few weeks is responsible
for releasing updated dietary guidelines
for Americans something they've been
doing every five years since 1980. now
you may be familiar with their work
because this is the same organization
that published the now thoroughly
debunked and ridiculed and Infamous food
pyramid which was taught as gospel when
I was in elementary school this was just
assumed that it was the way to go and
they taught the food pyramid until
actual nutrition experts pointed out
that the recommendations on the food
pyramid were ridiculous and wrong and
extremely dangerous to your health
its biggest problem there are many
problems with the food pyramid including
just how the foods are classified and
how overly simplified it all is but its
biggest problem was that it recommended
a diet consisting primarily of
carbohydrates with almost no fats on the
assumption that all carbs are good and
all fats are bad
the developers of these recommendations
were by the way persuaded in part by
lobbyists for the grain industry to make
grain the base of the pyramid this is
what convinced them that uh the grain
industry thought about threw a bunch of
money at them and then they said you
know what I think grain is great I think
it should be like the only thing people
eat
this strategy of recommending that
Americans eat whatever type of food has
the best lobbying firms behind it
apparently didn't have great results for
the overall health of Americans indeed
as the dietary guidelines advisory
committee continued to work and
continued to publish newer and newer
guidelines Americans just continue to
get fatter and fatter
there is no evidence that this
government initiative is helping anyone
and lots of evidence that it's hurting
people which only means that they'll
continue doing exactly what they've
always done and they'll get more and
more funding to do it because that's how
it works with the government as we have
seen time and time again
and with Dr Fatima Cody Stanford as one
of the quacks at the helm this time
around there's no reason to think that
the results will improve at all Stanford
a form again a foremost expert on
Obesity she teaches a subject at Harvard
Medical School she's got a she's a
doctor at uh Mass General Hospital
and she says that fatness is if not a
mental disorder then a disease of the
brain
the distinction by the way between
mental disorders and diseases of the
brain is of course never made clear by
anyone like nobody in in the medical or
psychiatric industry can even explain
the difference between the two things
they constantly conflate the two mental
disorders and brain diseases but she
insists that um that diet and exercise
have almost nothing to do with making
you fat she made this case a couple of
weeks ago to a visibly incredulous
journalist on 60 Minutes listen to this
if you diet
you lose weight
right the number one cause of obesity is
genetics that means if you are born to
parents that have obesity you have a 50
to 85 percent likelihood of having the
disease yourself even with optimal diet
exercise
sleep management Stress Management so
when people see families that have
obesity the assumption is what are they
feeding those kids
those are bigoted assumptions so she
proposes that you could have a near
perfect diet you could jog three miles a
day you could never touch fast food you
could never touch fried food you could
eat no junk food everything's great and
you will still have up to an 85 percent
likelihood of being obese because your
parents are
you may do everything right and still
wake up one morning like Tim Allen in
the Santa Claus suddenly morbidly obese
with a white beard and flying reindeer
parked in your front yard that's science
apparently
though despite how she presents it
um of course the reality is that obesity
cannot be simply passed down to a child
like eye color it would never be
accurate to say well I have my mom's
eyes my grandpa's jawline and my dad's
beer gut if it was that simple then
um you know if it was if it was simply
passed down like brown eyes and
pronounced jaw lines are passed down we
should see morbid obesity at similar
rates across the world and through
history but we don't we see it here in
this place at this time in history
because people have never had more food
to eat
um or more processed food to eat or more
sugary food to eat and they've also
never been more sedentary
if we see obesity running in a family
it's not because Mom and Dad passed down
their fat genes unless by that we mean
that a child is so fat that he's
literally wearing his dad's pants no
obesity runs in families because
children will generally eat what their
parents eat and they'll follow their
parents example and they'll sit for five
hours a day staring at screens if that's
what their parents do and allow them to
do
and the the inherent contradiction here
is that of course if people like Dr
Stanford are involved in creating any
sort of dietary guidelines at all then
they must acknowledge that your diet
plays a very important role what's the
point of the dietary guidelines you're
working on if the diet doesn't matter
why would we even be discussing diet
if it's just a matter of genetics anyway
it would be like issuing dietary
guidelines to help Americans change
their blood type
it's a total contradiction there's no
solution to the contradiction like so
many other contradictions from the
so-called expert class this is this one
is left to just hang out there and hope
that none of us will notice it
and as for that expert class it must be
said that the the laughable claim
that obesity running in families is
proof of an obesity Gene
this is exactly the kind of bad science
the kind of propaganda masquerading as
science
that has made people totally distrust
nearly everyone in nearly every
profession related at all to science
we have reached a critical mass no pun
intended and the public simply cannot
endure any more lies from the science
and medicine expert class we can't deal
with it anymore we can't listen to any
more of it
and more and more people are getting to
the point where they're saying I don't
want to hear I don't believe anything
you people say anymore
we've had enough
there's only so much you can take
but it's important to realize what this
particular lie is meant to accomplish
accomplish indeed most of the lies from
the medical industry have this same goal
and it's the goal I mentioned at the top
the objective
is to turn
you know people into fat pathetic
helpless rotund little roly-polies
waddling around from place to place
mindless and thoughtless driven by
Instinct and easily heard it in whatever
Direction our Bettors want us to go
they want us to believe that we have no
control over our lives over our minds
over our bodies
self-acceptance self-affirmation is the
highest virtue in our age because
self-acceptance in the way that they
mean it is defeat
that's what it is it is admitting defeat
and they want us defeated and submissive
simply accept your current mental and
physical state make yourself comfortable
with it satiate yourself uh distract
yourself numb yourself
by engaging a lot of a lot of you know
uh by just watching things on TV and
looking at your phone a lot
because you cannot change and you cannot
choose and you cannot do anything for
yourself
that's the message
but of course if you really don't want
to accept it if there's something about
yourself that you really don't like well
then the next option is to take drugs
and get surgeries
because remember it's all a disease
whatever it is you don't like about
yourself it's automatically a disease
whatever it is it's a disease so it's
not your fault
which is why you might as well accept it
and even embrace it and be proud of it
or you could treat it as a disease and
go get medicine for it another
contradiction
medicine or surgeries which they'll be
happy to provide of course for a hefty
fee
so that they can be richer and you can
be poorer
so we're going to add that to it poor
fat helpless and miserable
that's their vision for you and for me
and a vision that we should all
certainly reject
now let's get to our headlines
the daily wire doubled in size during
2022 and that fast growth is not
stopping as we head into 2023 and are
hiring for several different roles
already if you need to hire for your
business and you want an easier way to
find qualified candidates well you got
to head to ziprecruiter.com Welsh and
try it for free ZipRecruiter uses
powerful technology to find the right
candidate for your job see a candidate
you like well you can easily send them a
personal invite so they're more likely
to apply their user-friendly dashboard
makes it easy to filter review and rate
your candidates all from one place let
zip recruiter help you find the best
roles for all less people best people
for all of your roles four out of five
employers who post on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
you can see for yourself how easy it is
go to ziprecruiter.com Walsh to try
ZipRecruiter for free again that's
ziprecruiter.com
w-a-l-s-h zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
like we talked about yesterday the
Monterey Park uh mass shooting is not
terribly useful to the media now that it
turns out that their anti-asian hate
crime narrative doesn't really hold up
so they'll of course try to make it a
gun control thing and that's what
they're doing right now before they move
on because the gun control narrative
unfortunately for them doesn't drive
ratings nearly as much as some of these
other narratives do but on the topic of
gun control I thought this segment on
MSNBC this was yesterday
um was notable for how how much
absurdity they were able to pack into
like I think this is about two minutes
and let's listen to this
we choose to live like this it doesn't
have to be this way we choose to live in
a country and and this one of the guns
at least one of the guns I want to play
the sound
um so I get this right but it is it is
believed by the LA County Sheriff
um that one of the guns was probably not
legally possessed by the shooter let me
play that sound for you
the weapon that we recovered at that
second scene I'm describing as a
magazine fed
semi-automatic assault pistol not an
assault rifle but an assault pistol that
had an extended large capacity magazine
attached to it I believe the weapon that
was recovered
at the Alhambra location is not legal to
have here in the state of California
scenario Shannon describes precisely
and so while the solution seems to be
slowly and incrementally working in
places where elections succeed in
putting in place politicians who do
smart things to make us safer until
we're all safe No One Is Safe this was a
gun probably purchased somewhere else as
the sheriff said they're not legal to
have in California
Shannon's right on the money with regard
to this weakest link observation
replete on social media right now are
people saying look at that California
has some of the most strictest gun laws
in the nation and even they couldn't
escape
a mass shooting well yeah that's right
because you know why because you're only
as good as it says as the next the next
nearest state with the weakest gun laws
we need a national federal solution here
and it doesn't have to be just banning
all guns but we've got to act regionally
and nationally
hmm
so there's a few things to go over there
um and they like as I said they packed a
lot into it but so first of all we have
this phrase assault pistol uh which is a
new one to me I'd heard of the uh
assault rifle and I I was never clear on
what an assault right I don't own an
assault rifle is nobody knows what an
assault rifle looks an assault rifle
okay I know what assault rifle is
broadly an assault rifle is whatever
type of rifle uh the media finds scary
which is really all of them so so then I
guess context clues assault pistol is a
pistol that is particularly scary to the
media and to the left which again is all
pistols the whole I I mean putting the
word assault I know in front of a weapon
it's like
what yes any weapon can be used in the
course of an assault it can be used to
assault somebody
but then again any physical object well
maybe not any but many physical objects
those that can be that are hard or solid
can be picked up and wielded in any sort
of way
those can also be used in an assault
certainly a knife can be used so is
there an assault knife your hands can be
used in an assault
that's the vast majority of assaults
that happen uh throughout the country
every day
somebody using their fists
so do you have a salt Fists
so that's the first problem and then we
hear this statement from the anchor
there where she says well you know
nobody is safe until we're all safe
if we aren't all safe then nobody is
safe what
no no no that's see that's not how this
works at all actually that's definitely
not how this works
I'm not quite sure what you are even
trying to express there
until we're all safe nobody is safe
no you're you're safety look nobody is
100 safe
if you're a mortal being living anywhere
on the planet you're not 100 safe
there's always there are always dangers
lurking out there around every corner
um
but you can definitely increase your
relative safety
um and that's gonna to begin with me
dependent on where you live it depends
on location
so where I live I'm going to be a lot
safer
than someone who lives for example in
like the worst parts of Los Angeles
the worst parts of Los Angeles being the
entire city
so I'm gonna be a lot safer Island
there are people that can be a lot safer
than me if they live all the way out in
the country
that's an even safer place
so your your safety if you're living out
in the country and you've got uh 15
acres of land and you know there's
nobody around
the chance of you falling victim to
violent crime
unless it's violent crime coming from
inside your own house like a domestic
thing but the the chances of you falling
victim to a violent crime from someone
outside of your own household is
practically non-existent
whereas if you live in uh certain parts
of many cities your chances are Sky High
but your own your your own safety living
out in the country with your 15 Acres
that's uh that's not dependent on
everyone else being safe
why is she saying this though well then
we get it from
the other talking head that they brought
on
who said that
who said that well uh if you know there
are some states that have stricter gun
laws than others California has very
strict gun laws
it's acknowledged by
the law enforcement official in the
press conference
that the type of firearm that was used
to carry out this mass shooting is
already illegal in California it could
not it cannot be made more illegal that
they can pass another law making it
illegal again
but that's going to be redundant
if the first law making illegal was was
not totally effective then the second
law probably won't be either
which that in and of itself should put
an end to the gun control narrative for
this crime
because you you want to make it about
gun laws well whatever gun law you would
propose that would have supposedly
stopped this that's already on the books
in California and it didn't stop it
how do they get around that they say
well there are other states that don't
have these laws
and they're the they're the weak links
see now we're all all the states now are
links in a chain
and if you don't have if your laws are
not as tyrannical and oppressive as the
state next to you then you are now the
weak weak link
which means that this is not they're not
just using this as a platform to launch
an attack on the Second Amendment uh
they're also of course using this as an
attack on states rights
and we all have to be on the same page
we all have to have the same laws
because if California has certain laws
and they're not working for California
but you're a neighboring state and you
have different laws then well they can
just turn and blame you so it's all your
fault somehow
and then what happens what happens when
all that we would totally abolish states
rights which are mostly fictional and
have essentially been fictional really
since the the end of the Civil War
we abolish states rights
let's say they pass whatever federal gun
ban they want
still doesn't solve the problem because
people are still getting guts and well
then what do you do now you look at the
other countries of the world and it's
therefore well now we need a global now
we need Global laws
which which obviously is the next step
all right here's uh there's a report
from daily wire let's back up a few days
to get this story and then we'll have
the update
um a female California teenager in San
Diego County told local officials
Wednesday that she was exposed to male
genitalia inside a YMCA women's locker
room after finishing a workout Rebecca
Phillips 17 said during the public
comments section at the January 11th
Santee city council meeting that the
exposure happened two weeks ago after
she completed swimming laps and cleaning
up in the Cameron Family YMCA women's
locker room
as I was showering after my workout this
is a Phillips quoting said I saw a naked
male in the women's locker room I
immediately went back into the shower
terrified and hid behind their flimsy
excuse for a curtain until he was gone
Philip said that she asked YMCA
management about the facility's
transgender policy and she said the
family Recreation Center confirmed to
her that staff allowed the man to shower
wherever he pleased
uh Phillips told City officials as long
as they're not a red flag on Megan's Law
California sex offender registry a grown
male can shower alongside a teenage girl
at your YMCA location here in Santee I
was made to feel as though I had done
something wrong when I talked to people
at the YMCA so this was a
this was a male pervert
who uh was fully naked in the women's
locker room around minors
and one of these girls complained
and was made to feel like a bigot for
complaining
the phrase victim blaming gets thrown
around a lot
and and usually in circumstances where
it's not at all appropriate but this is
if you're wondering what victim blaming
really looks like this is what it looks
like it's this
you have a female a minor who was
sexually harassed
by a naked male in her locker room
she complains about it and she's treated
like a bigot
essentially the message to her and to
every woman and every girl
is hey if you don't want uh naked men
around you in your locker rooms to deal
with it go home don't don't come here
anymore
this is this is your problem
so that's victim blaming
and you know also by the way sexual the
term sexual harassment is thrown around
quite a lot yesterday in the daily
cancellation we had examples of women
who were you know working out at the gym
recording themselves and then claim that
they're harassed because a man briefly
looks in their direction or God forbid
tries to speak to them and that becomes
harassment that's not though
on the other hand a man getting walking
into the woman's locker room getting
fully naked that's sexual harassment
that's what that's what that looks like
and it looks hideous
speaking of looking hideous the uh local
CBS affiliate has an update to this
report and they the the guy who went to
locker room he's been talking to the
media he's very proud of himself has no
shame
let's watch a little bit of this report
people entire families are coming up to
get their picture taken and to introduce
me to their children and wood is not
done fighting she's planning to speak
next Wednesday at the Santee city
council meeting it's important that they
finally get to hear the truth and they
finally just pause it for a second
because this is
I mean this is literally just an out of
shape Dennis Rodman I mean this is like
uh if Wesley Snipes had a baby with
Elton John
and this is the dude that's coming into
the women's locker room
not even
once again not that it matters of course
but this is this doesn't qualify as even
dressing like a woman
have you ever seen a woman that dresses
like this
he's dressed like a homeless circus
clown this is not no no woman looks like
this or dresses like this
again not that it matters even if he was
really pulling off the look it wouldn't
make it okay to be in the locker room
but he's not doing that much
let's keep watching face on this scary
transgender woman who was
misgendered and despite threats of
violence wood says she's not scared you
know I I know how to give an insult out
and I know what areas to kick and punch
you know at least enough to be able to
run until I can get to my car and get
out of here and at the meeting she'll
have the support of her Aqua sisters my
husband and I are thinking about putting
some signs together that say we support
Chrissy so that we have you know the
visual friendship through thick and thin
Austin grab is joining me now Austin I
feel like a big part of the story that's
either been a misconception or people
are just forgetting about is that wood
has fully transitioned into a woman and
was in the woman's bathroom yeah that's
right Wale in fact she says she is a
woman and she really wants to drive home
oh she says it she says years ago
um and that you know he says it she is
uh she is a woman and and she says she's
a woman period and that's where it ends
absolutely and let's transition
ourselves into the other side of the
song 17 year old girl he said what are
we hearing from her yeah interesting he
said it well that's it he said it
Phillips here last night at the protest
and I have tried to get in touch with
her I left a message yesterday at her
workplace but I have not had a phone
call back certainly we would like to
speak to her but I haven't heard from
her and I haven't heard any more public
comments from her it will be interesting
to see if she comes out to that city
council meeting next week certainly
she's already had her voice heard there
now wood is going to have her voice
heard there as well it would be
interesting to see if the two were there
at the same time absolutely you you
definitely want to hear from that 17
year old and how she's even responding
to the protest Austin thank you very
much let's dive deeper into that part of
the story and how this incident got into
the public Limelight last week that 17
year old girl that we were just talking
about her name is Rebecca Phillips she
got off to speak of Santee City
um I don't know how much longer this
goes on so they're remarking on the fact
that they can't get a hold of the 17
year old girl and both of these
both of these uh so-called journalists
there so we tried to get a hold of her
we can't get she's not talking to us I
wonder why I wonder why she's not
talking to us
I don't know 17 year old girl being
smeared as a bigot by the media like
you've already come out against her
you're right now coming out against her
by affirming this pervert male as a
woman
how do we know he's a woman well because
he says so
and they think it's really important to
clarify just to clarify now uh this
person
says says she's a woman period
said it that's it it was said so that's
all
fully transitioned where we are informed
he fully transitions this is a full
transition
so what else are we supposed to say
there's uh there's this that's it that's
that period they put the end of the they
said period that's the end of the
discussion
so after saying that then they called
the 17 year old girl and say hey by the
way we're at the media uh we wanted to
know why you're such a disgusting bigot
hey can you give us a call back 17 year
old girl and let us know we want to know
why are you such a transphobic bigot
that's going to cause this poor trans
woman to kill herself we wanted to know
more details about your bigotry please
give us a call back
these people are beneath contempt
utter scum
and that's you know and I'm I'm even
angrier as always at the at everyone
else in this that we've seen
you know in this story
I'm angry at everyone
else even aside from the guy dressing up
as as a woman I mean he's the number one
culpit culprit of course
he's a pervert predator and should be in
prison for sexually harassing minor
girls he should simply be in prison for
that for the rest of his life this is
not something that we need in society
he's not doing anything to help society
that we don't we don't need him and so
we should just throw him in a cage and
lock it and keep him there at a minimum
but
then you look at everybody else I mean
how they we heard from the woman
it's like an older woman imagine being
like you're an actual woman okay you're
you are a real woman
and
you see you hear a story about a man
disrobing and exposing himself to a 17
year old girl and you take the man's
side
all right let's watch a little more of
this it's marking the debate here's some
of what you got to say as I was
showering after my workout I saw a naked
male in the women's locker room
I immediately went back into the shower
terrified and hid behind their flimsy
excuse for a curtain until he was gone I
was made to feel as though I had done
something wrong when I talked to people
at the YMCA
somehow the indecent exposure of a male
to a female minor was an inconvenience
to them
foreign
I
how deranged do you have to be we just
saw they only gave us a you know a short
snippet of the 17 year old girl but
you've got you've got her on one hand
and even in that
10 seconds they show of her address at
the city council meeting
we can tell that she's a 17 year old
girl normal person
who had to witness this hideous
disgusting excuse for a man disrobing in
front of her and she was quite
traumatized by it and Afraid
as any 17 year old girl would be as any
woman would there's any any female would
be in that situation
so you've got her on one hand the other
hand
you've got the Dennis Rodman look like
again how deranged do you have to be
like in what state does your soul have
to be in to see these two people
and come to the conclusion that the dude
is in the right that you're on the
dude's side
but what makes it really evil
you know this is my point that what
makes it really evil is that I don't
believe
that anyone actually does think that the
guy is in the right
I just I don't believe that the two news
anchors or reporters that we saw there
I I don't think that any of them are
looking at this guy and thinking well
yeah that's a woman all right that's a
woman if I ever saw one
none of them think that but they're
going along with it
for ideological course political reasons
all right
similar uh subject here is the report
from the daily wire United Nations
women's rights committee rejected a
pro-life organization's request to
screen the daily wires what is a woman
after declaring the groundbreaking
documentary did not align with the
panel's values
the committee on the status of women
um referred to within the global body as
NGO
cswny and a convener for the United
Nations annual meeting on women's rights
rejected the international youth
coalition's request to hold a screening
of the film starring Matt Walsh at an
upcoming conference because it did not
adhere to their new guidelines so this
is a the UN at this committee associated
with the un uh they're saying you can't
screen what is a woman because it
doesn't adhere to their guidelines uh
the letter turning down the proposal
said unfortunately your request to host
an event has been denied as your event
does not align with NGO
cswny's values and or mandate
the summary rejection stunned Austin
Roos president of the Center for Family
and human rights the youth coalition's
parent organization
he uh he said quote how ironic is it
that a conference on women does not want
to consider the question what is a woman
it's also unfortunate that this U.N
conference is not interested in diverse
voices now
obviously nobody is surprised that the
U.N is not interested in having my film
screened I don't think anyone's
surprised by that I'm not surprised to
learn that it doesn't align with the
un's guidelines
I agree in fact it does not align with
their with their with their guidelines
or their values
in fact I would be
I would be embarrassed I would I would
be not just I'd be in ch I'd be ashamed
if they if they were actually allowed to
screen it if the UN said oh yeah that we
have no problem with that one yeah that
that adheres to our values
I probably I think I would retire from
the business I think at that point I I
would have to if I found out that I made
a film that adheres to the un's
guidelines
I would have to retire in shame so in a
certain way I'm quite relieved that they
turned it down
um
but that doesn't
change the irony here or how absurd it
actually is that this is a keep in mind
that the name of the committee or the
conference it's not it's not simply a
committee for women or whatever it's
it's a committee about the status of
women that's what they're interested in
the status of women
and so if we want to examine the status
of women in the world then probably the
first question we need to answer is
um what are they and do they exist to
begin with
that's uh if you're if you're trying to
figure out anyone's status the first
thing you need to know is whether uh
that person or that type of person
exists
and that's something that that's a that
is a a at a minimum a Live question on
the left they're not quite sure
not quite sure if women exist to begin
with in any kind of meaningful sense
but that's not a question that they want
to obviously examine at the U.N
another report for the daily wire I
think is important in one generation the
world has experienced seismic shifts in
the way we communicate and relate to one
another but these changes are coming at
a high cost particularly to our children
uh most teenagers 97 report being online
every day and nearly half say they're
online almost constantly but Recent
research from scientists at the
University of North Carolina shows that
all of this time on social media is
linked to changes in the teen brain by
looking at brain scans of middle
schoolers between the ages of 12 and 15
neuroscientists at UNC found that
frequent social media users at age 12
showed heightened sensitivity to social
rewards from peers over time teenagers
who were less engaged with social media
at age 12 showed less interest in Social
rewards over time
Gene twang a psychology professor at San
Diego State University and author of
igen has also sounded the alarm on the
link between social media use and
anxiety and depression in teens there's
a substantial link to depression and
that link tends to be stronger among
girls the more time the teen
particularly a teen girl spends using
social media the more likely it is that
she'll be depressed according to twang
any new habit or learned behavior leaves
its imprint on the brain the fact that
the brain is imprinted by social media
use should not come as a surprise but
most parents who let their children
create social media accounts are
probably unaware of the extent to which
these social media accounts are training
their children to seek peer approval or
what the long-term consequences may be
um so this is
just the latest bit of scientific
evidence
that it is not good for children for
them to sit around all day staring at
their phones remember 50 and I think the
numbers probably low but according to
the latest data latest surveys 50 of
teens and adolescents say that they're
online constantly
and by constantly and anyone who's ever
been around a kid in this category knows
that constantly really means constantly
like they're never not they sleep and
then they wake up and they're staring at
the phone the entire day no matter what
else they're doing they have the phone
and they're looking at their phone I
don't think we need
we certainly
have never needed to wait around
for scientific evidence that this is not
a healthy way to live
and I don't need I don't need any
scientific analysis or any study to tell
me this is not a healthy way for kids to
live
the only the only thing science will do
is tell us in precisely what sort of
ways it is unhealthy so we know that
it's extremely unhealthy
and we can figure out a lot of the ways
that it's not healthy
um driving the Obesity epidemic is one
thing
that's the least of it
but then science I suppose can come back
around and get a little bit more
specific give us some of the details
none of these details are surprising
this is not this is not a
a it's it's not even a human existence
is the human beings were not meant to
live this way
and whenever we can look at the way that
we're living our lives right now
you know this is this part of learning
from history and learning from our
ancestors and I know people these days
they want to pretend that our ancestors
and uh have nothing to teach us and
nothing to tell tell us we want to sever
ourselves entirely from our ancestors
um not listen to the testimony of those
who came before us but that's a very
foolish way to live and if you were to
listen to them then you know you should
look at the way you're living and and um
you could ask yourself like what what is
it about Modern Life that would be
entirely foreign
to our ancestors
and just because it'd be entirely
foreign to our ancestors doesn't mean
that it's necessarily wrong there's a
lot of modern medicine at least the
legitimate parts of it that would be
foreign to our ancestors
antibiotics would have been formed
doesn't mean that we shouldn't take them
but
having a little device
that you carry around all the time
and having your entire life center
around this device that is one of those
things that is unprecedented in history
that there's no analog for it
many of the things that we think are
unprecedented in modern history when you
look at it you see that well this is
just a version of something that existed
before nothing new Under the Sun as it
says as we say actually there are some
things that are new Under the Sun
smartphones on the internet are new
Under the Sun there is no analog for it
nothing comparable to it historically
this is an entirely new thing
it might be one of the only entirely new
things
and so this is entirely new thing that
we have decided to completely structure
our lives around
that in and of itself doesn't make it
wrong but it is a reason to examine it
and say hmm no one's ever lived this way
before is
are we on yeah we are we are diverging
off a completely different path
is this the right thing to do
I think in this case it's obviously not
and clearly when your kids grow up on
this stuff and all they ever do is is
use the internet and their whole life is
structured around it
as they found in the study I mean among
other things makes them a lot more
susceptible to peer pressure a lot more
susceptible to influence uh much more
desperate for approval and affirmation
kids already are inclined in that way
they they need approval any affirmation
that's not that's not an unhealthy
desire for a child
but for kids that are on social media
this is their entire life
you gotta I mean you you just you ha I
could
keep saying it a million times over and
I will continue to say it you have to
rescue your children from this you just
must you can't you cannot you must force
your your children to have real
childhoods and to live real human lives
you know
um and they're they're not gonna like it
if you've allowed them to use the phone
up until now and you take that stuff
away and if you allow them to play video
games six hours a day and you take that
away they're not gonna like it at first
it's it's they're going to react like a
heroin addict when you take the heroin
needle away but but it's for their own
good
foreign you just have to for their own
sake
all right let's get to our comment
section
[Music]
Joshua van says Matt Walsh literally
just said we should assume the shooter
was black because it was a crime against
Asians wow let's not mention most Mass
Shooters are white LOL wow
well I'm glad you're impressed uh no I I
said that if we were going to assume the
ray if we are going to assume the race
of the Monterey Park shooter as many in
the media did then statistically the
most probable assumption would be that
he's black turns out that he's not black
or white he's Asian
um as for
most Mass Shooters being white again
uh unfortunately you're wrong a mass
shooting is defined as a shooting where
multiple people are hurt or killed
that's what a mass shooting is
now you're going based on the definition
of mass shooting your definition of mass
shooting is basically the types of
shootings the media pays attention to
and if that's your definition then yes
the majority of those are carried out by
white people I mean almost 100 of them
like 95 are carried out by white people
the ones that the media pays attention
to that's not the actual definition mass
shooting is is just multiple people
being hurt or killed and when you Define
mass shooting that way which is how law
enforcement agencies Define it then the
majority of those are carried out by
black men
uh by a white wide margin by the way not
by white people that's
again a statistical reality
uh recruit says Matt I cannot put up
with this grifting anymore I'm sick of
having to pay for daily wire plus I'm
sick of the ads I will settle for no
less than you showing up to my front
door and telling me what you have to say
personally and paying me for my time
that is
that is one potential business strategy
I'll I'll run that up the flagpole and
see what they think
um Julie says Matt I think you're
eventually going to surpass Rush
Limbaugh in popularity I look forward to
it uh no I I I won't and no here's the
thing that nobody ever will
um no one will ever be there's not going
to be a you know after Rush Limbaugh
died there was of course there's a
conversation about who's the new Rush
Limbaugh who's going to take over who's
going to take the banner and be the and
um
there's not ever going to be Rush
Limbaugh as well as a singular Talent
um at a particular time in history
revolutionized his industry of talk
radio and uh it's a different world now
um and there's not ever going to be
another one that's that's it
um
U.S marine says Matt is the only person
I know that hates cake is passionately
as the no pineapple and pizza crowd it's
impressive honestly well that's not
quite fair I think I I don't hate cakes
yeah this is this is the misconception
okay I've already said I'll eat cake
obviously if someone offers me cake I'm
gonna eat it because the only other
option is to say no I don't want any
cake which who would ever say that so
I'll eat it
um speaking of obesity I'll eat whatever
junk food you put in front of my face
but it's not it's overrated it's vastly
overrated why and and and it doesn't
deserve the pride of place that it gets
is my point
um
orange banana says Matt now that we've
settled the pie versus cake dispute how
about this yogurt or pudding
how is that a dispute like would anyone
choose a yogurt over pudding you could
choose yogurt or pudding is anyone going
with yogurt
it's arguable whether you should eat
yogurt even if it's the only option
yogurt is kind of gross it tastes a
little bit like worms especially Greek
yogurt
um but there's there's no contest there
at all
Glock Tech says it's so nice to hear
Matt pronounce latinx as latinks instead
of Latin X the word itself is an
Abomination against Spanish grammar and
the latter pronunciation just further
attacks on the Spanish language because
X isn't pronounced as x in Spanish
the Democrats and their woke culture
report to be the tolerant ones but the
non-hispanic who compromise so many of
their ranks presumed to uh comprise of
many of the ranks presumed to tell
actual Hispanics how to speak their own
language the lack of insight is
egregious
yeah I don't even it's like even
conservatives
when they're making fun of the latinx
thing will will themselves pronounce it
Latin X
but you're already giving the left too
much ground when you do that
I I won't use their false pronunciation
even when making fun of it because
that's not like La how would you
pronounce if you want the word Aladdin X
then I guess you'd have to spell it
l-a-t-i-n-e-x like maybe then you could
justify latex but l-a-t-i-n-x is latinx
that's how you pronounce that
um
and finally Harry lagman says brilliant
episode I think the girl in the second
video in the cancellation had seen other
guys staring in gym videos and was
expecting the same thing to happen she
had been thinking about this
hypothetical situation I was angry
already before a guy used his eyeballs
to look vaguely in her Direction a
terrible crime for him to commit I'm
lucky enough to see the best side of
women every day of my life but this is
one of life's irritations a certain type
of woman spending hours
trying to look as attractive as possible
and then blaming men for looking at them
some women do this all the time they
want men women men to behave in one
specific way only and anything else is
harassment it's irrational yet some
people take this nonsense seriously yeah
I think that might partly actually I
don't think that's really the
explanation I don't think that either of
the women in these videos
were actually upset I think this is a
trap that's a whole particle reason why
they're recording themselves at the gym
and I know women aren't the only I see
this sometimes I see it sometimes myself
at the gym not just women but men
recording themselves too I don't get it
I don't know why you need to do that and
if you really do feel the new need to do
that you feel like you want to record
yourself working out then you could stay
at your house for that
that that's one thing about recording
yourself
in a public place
it's annoying to everyone and it's
strange but also there are other people
who are now in the recording who
probably don't want to be especially at
a gym
most normal people the last thing they
want in the world is unless you're
getting paid as a fitness instructor
instructor the last thing you want in
the world is to be on video when you're
working out
so I think this was just a trap that
they said I don't think she was actually
authentically angry at all
but either way
they were the bad guys and deserve to be
canceled
Jeremy's razors is offering a great deal
that ends soon 40 off on all razors why
the discount well I'm glad you asked a
year ago when Joe Biden tried to force a
vaccine mandate upon private employers
and some 85 million Americans the daily
wire told him where to stick it we sued
the federal government and won after a
6-3 ruling in our favor from Supreme
Court the Mandate was dead and together
we kicked the government's ass so on the
first anniversary of this tremendous
victory for all Americans Delaware CEO
and God King Jeremy boring has issued a
special decree on the razors that bear
his name right now and only for a
limited time all Jeremy's razors are 40
off that's right 40 that means you can
get a kit with a Precision 5 razor and
flip back trimmer shave cream post shave
balm extra blades and a handy travel
case for just 35.99 that's a savings of
just 20 of uh 24 the Biden
Administration and totalitarian cronies
were cut down and now we can Rejoice by
drinking their tears enjoying our
freedom and looking damn good while
doing it get 40 off Jeremy's razors
before the deal Ends by going to
jeremy'srazors.com now let's get to our
daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel shikari Richardson you
may vaguely remember the name of someone
who was complaining a while ago about
being persecuted for some reason or
another and supposedly was all racist or
somehow or something all these
controversies bleed together in the mind
and it's hard to keep them straight so
to clarify Richardson is the female
track star who was disqualified from the
Olympics a couple of years ago because
she tested positive for marijuana and
many people including Richardson herself
complained that the rule against
marijuana use is absurd and pointless as
marijuana is not likely to give you an
advantage in competitive Sports this is
probably true I guess but
me being the victim blamer that I am I I
always more so wondered why she would
use marijuana when she's in the middle
of qualifying for the Olympics given the
fact that it's a banned substance it may
not be necessary to ban it at the
Olympics but it's even less necessary
for Olympians to use it
and if I was hoping to compete in the
Olympics and the Olympics had a rule
outline the consumption of anything like
if they had a rule out long the
consumption of Cheez-Its before
competing and they had to test to
determine who had used Cheez-Its I'd be
severely disappointed I'd be confused I
wouldn't agree with the rule but I still
just wouldn't eat the Cheez-Its as
difficult as it would be to abstain
because it would be more important to me
that I get to follow my dream and
compete
but that's just me so she chose to
sacrifice the Olympics so that she could
smoke weed um that makes her the
and that's really the story there it
should have been but Richardson became
famous for not racing at the Olympics a
famous victim of Olympic rules that
apply to everyone but somehow were
personally oppressive to her
specifically and given that Richardson's
primary claim to famous her victimhood
it perhaps is no surprise that she is or
at least became a totally insufferable
brat which leads us to the latest update
in the Richardson victimhood Saga where
now she finds herself kicked off of an
American Airlines flight after refusing
to stop using her phone before takeoff
she recorded two videos documenting this
confrontation with the flight attendants
and other people on her flight
apparently convinced that she comes off
as the good guy in The Exchange
but you can judge for yourself here's
the video
place it all the way under the seat in
front of you larger carry-on luggage not
working today if you have small vacation
time such as cell phones tablets and
smart watches okay please switch them
recording me but you jumped in my video
so I called you because you jumped in my
videos you're harassing me at this point
so I think you should stop I think you
should stop I think you should stop
y'all see him right y'all see him right
okay okay but I'm sorry it's not me okay
talk to him no no no don't talk to me
like that I'm gonna do not talk to me
like that do not talk to me like that
tell him to stop if you do not know
what's going on do not yell at me you
can stop recording no I'm not going to
start recording because I was making a
video to myself recording I'm going to
not stop recording
and this video will show what you're
doing so I appreciate it
are you talking to me thank you like to
know
again again with the taking the video in
public think why are you why are you
taking a video to begin with on your
flight no one cares that you're you're
on a flight you're taking a flight no
we've that's not interesting why do you
think that needs to be documented not
everything needs to be documented okay
we don't need we don't need
documentation especially not all the
documentation anyone does anymore is of
their face is a selfie or selfie video
here's my face on a plane here's my face
doing this here's my face walking down
the street nobody cares it's not
interesting
and I know that I sound like a hypocrite
because I'm in front of a camera every
single day but that's also my job and I
can tell you even in my job like it
trust me you see too much of me as it is
it could be a lot worse I mean all the
time I've got social media the social
social media team here telling me Oh you
should do this video doing this or that
we need a selfie video of you doing this
I'm not doing that no one needs to see
that it's it's not interesting like give
me a reason why I should be on camera
some reason and I'll do it but we don't
need you don't need to have your face on
camera every second of the day
okay
now in the second video which I won't
force you to watch
she argues with another passenger who
rightly blames her for holding up the
plane and making him miss his connection
she chides him for um not being
chivalrous and and you know not standing
up to defend her against the
intimidating flight attendants and he
responds to her by saying and I quote I
don't give it which is both an eloquent
argument and the morally correct one in
this situation eventually Richardson has
escorted off the plane while the other
passengers applaud but the fact that
nearly everyone on the plane was against
her and that she had inconvenienced over
a hundred people for no reason at all
was not enough to convince her that she
was herself the villain of this story
instead she posted both videos to
Instagram while threatening legal action
against the airline for committing the
crime of I guess expecting her to follow
the rules that everyone else has to
follow
this is a theme for Richardson right she
really has trouble with requirements
that apply to everyone you don't have to
like the requirements okay but they
apply to everyone and no one else has a
problem everyone else manages to follow
them but you
why is it a problem for you everyone
else managed to not smoke weed before
they have to had to go race in the
Olympics you had an issue with it
everyone else manages to like not be
taking a selfie video right before
takeoff for some reason you can't handle
that
indeed she is personally injured by
these requirements the requirements are
an attack against her not against
everyone else who's just as subject to
them but against her because she is her
she is shikari Richardson and she is the
protagonist in the story of the human
species
now fortunately I don't have to go to
Great Lengths actually in this
cancellation to explain why Richardson
is in the wrong because it would seem
that most people are on the same page on
this one somewhat shockingly this is the
part that surprised me Richardson has
not garnered much public support even
after playing both the race and gender
card after the fact an Instagram post
that diligently avoids anything
resembling punctuation or proper
sentence structure Richardson wrote in
part
tell me if I'll be wrong to pursue legal
actions against the airline American
Airline not only did the man threaten me
but also an innocent bystander simply
just wanted a picture with me in the
beginning of the video you can hear a
Caucasian male state that he doesn't
give a f as a man that male flight
attendant is intimidating a woman also
the captain not doing anything to help
the situation and this flight attendant
has the Applause when I exited the plane
when I'm pretty serious to disrespect I
receive would not have happened if I was
a if I was a one of them
and I
I don't know
um one of them as in a white male I
guess is what she she meant to say
because of course
everyone on the plane would have been
perfectly happy to miss their connecting
flights if only the disturbance had been
caused by a white male I mean I'll never
forget the time and it's actually
happened a couple times when I I threw a
temper a random temper tantrum in first
class delayed the plane by 45 minutes
caused 32 passengers to miss their
connections and everyone in the plane
um they were so proud of me they shook
my hands one by one to thank me for it
while the flight attendant showered me
with free flight vouchers and extra bags
of complimentary peanuts that is a thing
that definitely happened in real life
and not just any fevered marijuana
soaked mind of shikari Richardson
anyway in this case her victim routine
seems to not be resonating as much as
she had hoped with the public it could
be that the public
has become suddenly intelligent and
Discerning which seems to be frank
extremely unlikely or it could just be
that people are simply sick and tired of
loud-mouthed crybabies with main
character syndrome who always seem to
find problems and drama in the sorts of
situations where everyone else manages
to get along just fine fine
it's perhaps interesting to note that
even as the public becomes increasingly
and unreasonably tolerant of
self-victimizing drama queens who look
for every you know opportunity to be
oppressed
they still don't want to deal with it on
an airplane
people these days will put up with your
shenanigans
in almost any situation that is until
your shenanigans might cause them to
miss a connection in Chicago
that seems to be where the line is drawn
and it's good that the line is drawn
somewhere
and that is why I must say indeed I
think we all say that Shakari Richardson
is today canceled and that'll do it for
this portion of the show as we move over
to the members block hope to see you
there if not talk to you tomorrow
Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]